depuis sa réouverture le 22 juin dernier
les sept salles de ce cinéma ont du mal
à se remplir
la fréquentation a baissé de 70% après
le continent à cause notamment du manque
de films au programme sur tous les films
américains véritable locomotive des
salles obscures
alors cet exploitant a dû s'adapter il a
fallu utiliser ce qu'on nous a mis à
disposition au niveau gouvernemental
c'est à dire le chômage partiel pour
diminuer les horaires du personnel
on lui a fallu qu'on adapte aussi
quelques séances qui qu'on supprime
quelques séances qui traditionnellement
ne tirez pas beaucoup le public
la ministre de la culture roselyne
bachelot a annoncé 100 millions d'euros
dead 50 millions pour compenser les
pertes de recettes de billetterie des
salles de cinéma et l'autre moitié sera
destinée au spectacle vivant cette
compagnie suisse de théâtre de rue à une
soixantaine de représentations annulées
depuis le mois de mars alors revenir
jouer devant un public était plus que
nécessaire et l' envie de se donner la
réplique encore plus farc
c'est du plaisir de revenir et voir du
simplement retrouvé du public et de
vêtements faire son métier
je dois avouer c'est un peu rageant de
voir d'autres personnes travaillent et
qui n'ont puisse pas faire notre job est
de se dire que les seules choses qui
peuvent se faire actuellement c'est des
beaux lots qui sont en dehors d'un
du livre du lien humain public social
ouais ça fait du bien de revenir un hot
dog on a eu un peu peur à un moment
donné on s'est tous demandé si on
n'allait pas tout ce faste et simplement
le chapeau dans la rue mais sans plus
faire de théâtre d'autres aides seront
alloués à la culture avec notamment 15
millions d'euros pour les festivals les
états généraux des festivals lancé à
avignon début octobre doivent se
poursuivre au printemps de bourges en
2021 pour permettre à tout le secteur
culturel de sortir la tête de l'eau